c'est grave a dit bonjour merci être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
journée de mobilisation aujourd'hui
mobilisation nationale contre cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage
qu'est ce qui cloche dans le texte
qu'est ce que vous dénonciez balle est
ronde et trois choses déjà c'est
l'hypocrisie du gouvernement puisque le
gouvernement il nous dit que il a bien
entendu ce que les que les allées les
organisations et les travailleurs
mobilisés déjà depuis plus d'un an sur
cette réforme là lui ont dit en
modifiant sa calcul c'est des règles de
calcul d'indemnisation alors qu'en fait
il nous a pas écoutés c'est le conseil
d'état qui a entaché d'illégalité c'est
cette facette son modèle de calcul des
indemnisations chômage
c'est une nouvelle formule qui va
baisser de 17% l'indemnisation du tout
les chômeurs fin de 17 jusqu'à 30%
l'indemnisation tous les chômeurs alors
qu'aujourd'hui il ya seulement 20 % des
chômeurs qui sont indemnisés et que la
moitié des indemnisations sont en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
vous savez il ya quatorze mille chômeurs
qui meurent chaque année du chômage donc
cette réforme là elle va encore faire en
sorte que moins de chômeurs soient
indemnisés et plus faiblement indemnisés
donc voilà moutons on dit que c'est un
gouvernement qui est hypocrite qui veut
mettre en place une réforme qui
assassine et pour mettre en place cette
réforme à chantier assassinat et ben il
fait que mentir il fait que mentir toute
la journée en disant qu'aujourd'hui ce
qui ne favorise pas l'emploi ce serait
une assurance chômage qui est trop
généreuse alors qu'aujourd'hui ce qui ne
favorise pas l'emploi c'est l'attitude
du patronat qui dans toutes les
entreprises toutes les entreprises est
en train de casser l'emploi quels sont
les professionnels les professions les
plus impactés par cette réforme chômage
il ya 2
il ya deux populations de travailleurs
précaires enfin deux catégories pauvres
professionnels de travailleurs précaires
qui seront impactées la première c'est
tous les travailleurs activités
discontinues c'est à dire tous ceux qui
enchaînent très vite des périodes de
travail et puis des périodes de deux de
chômage comme par exemple des maîtres
hôteliers les guides conférenciers des
saisonniers des intérimaires voilà
énormément de travailleurs précaires
c'est un million cent mille travailleurs
précaires qui seront en est qui sont en
activité discontinue parlons et qui
seront concernés passerait de cette
réforme là et puis la deuxième ce sont
tous les salariés multi employeurs
c'est à dire tous ceux qui sont un
salarié des salariés à temps partiel
parce que le vu que le but de cette
réforme là c'est de faire baisser le et
j'irai de le sjr pardon et de rendre en
gros de quelque sorte que l'assurance
l'indemnisation chômage soit le reflet
de l'activité
c'est à dire plus d'activité est réduite
ou discontinue et plus l'indemnisation
chômage sera faible et pour faire ça le
gouvernement il va abaisser grandement
le salaire journalier de référence à
partir duquel est calculée
l'indemnisation chômage
bon bah ça sera une autre conséquence
pour tous les salariés à temps partiel
puisque ça va rendre compliquée la
possibilité de cumuler une indemnisation
chômage est son salaire
donc tous les salariés à temps partiel
bay pourront plus cumuler donc ça c'est
les assistantes maternelles se sont les
ceux qui travaillent par exemple aussi
dans la prévention dans la sécurité
ceux qui sont en banque et sierre femmes
à tous les salariés à temps partiel en
dépit des oppositions syndicales le
gouvernement semble donc vouloir mener
au bout son idée et ténacité qu'on
observe au passage de beaucoup de lois
ces derniers temps quelles vont être les
grandes actions syndicales pour les
faire changer d'avis et est-ce que vous
avez d'ailleurs prévu une réunion avec
les partenaires sociaux mais écoutez il
ya deux ans déjà il ya la mobilisation
qui quand même qu'il ya dans ce pays
depuis le depuis le 4 mars du moins qui
s'est intensifiée le 4 mars avec
l'occupation de plus de 100 théâtre en
france mais aussi maintenant même en
europe il ya eu déjà des des grandes
manifestations depuis depuis décembre et
puis là il en a eu il y en a eu une
autre le le 2 mars
et puis là il y en aura une une
aujourd'hui une grande manifestation
départ de la départ de la place d'italie
à 14 heures et puis effectivement bien
il ya un front syndical aujourd'hui qui
est plutôt unissent cette question là en
tout cas dans la déclaration qui ne se
traduit pas encore aujourd'hui dans la
mobilisation
mais la cgt elle est force de
proposition en tout cas de date de
mobilisation qu'on espère la plus le
plus unitaire possible et temps avec
d'autres organisations syndicales mais
nous ce qui nous intéresse le plus ce
avec le plus de deux syndicats possible
de travailleurs possible puisque nous
conduit à la vérité c'est que cette
réforme là c'est bien la faire de tous
les travailleurs
puisqu'aujourd'hui le patronat s'il
arrive à être si fort dans les
entreprises à
à grasse ou chantage à l'emploi a
demandé qu'il ya des casses des conflits
sociaux dans les entreprises dans des
baisses de salaires ou d augmentation du
temps de travail c'est parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya la peur du chômage
voilà et ses peurs là elle doit changer
de camp et si on veut que cette peur
elle change de camp et dans l'annulation
cette réforme assurance chômage là c'est
déjà un premier temps merci beaucoup aux
pierres garde maudit d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire du comité national cgt des
chômeurs et des précaires